welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to
break down the outsider episode a is
finally here and the entry that I'm
calling Jack Attack has a lot to unpack
everything is really coming together now
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down all of the ins and outs
of the episode and it's ending there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want anything potentially ruined
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel as the finale is right around
the corner and you don't want to miss
what happens in the last few episodes
without the way thanks again for click
in the video now let's get into a
breakdown of the outsider episode 8
episode 8 centers around Ralph's getting
onboard with the investigation in order
to help save Claude the outsider has
been laying low going through a
transformation and due to its
vulnerability it's been using Jack to do
its dirty work
however this space is almost over and
the creature is ready to claim its next
victim time is short and due to Ralph's
disbelief of El cuoco the investigation
has stalled this has allowed the
creature to put the pieces in place for
the next part of its plan the episode
opens with Jack getting the police away
from his room by making a phone call and
saying that one of them has been shot
the place is being completely ransacked
but luckily for Jack they didn't find
the arsenal of weapons that would make
the Punisher blush he's got shotguns
rifles and even some night-vision
goggles that had me realizing that this
guy could easily play Sam Fisher in a
live action version of Splinter Cell we
then cut to a festival which is in the
midst of being set up in the town name
cave stock this isn't a real festival
but there's one called cave fest so yeah
if you're looking for somewhere to go
for the next 15 years then there's a
place this video was brought to you by K
Fest make sure you use the link in the
description below for 50% off anyway
there's a sign for tiger Corps cave and
I think this has a lot going on with it
in the episode we learn that al cuoco
chooses to hide out in a cave I know
it's a bear one this is a clear
reference to that claw could be because
he scratches people and Tiger could be
because he's an endangered animal and
we're already reaching however the cave
setting is similar
the book and this is where the monster
ended up hiding out after the maitland
clothes were discovered at the barn we
learned that el cuoco has been panicked
by the unearthing of the CCTV that
cleared Terry's name and because of this
he's had to massively change his MO alko
go in the episode make sure it's in the
exact same place as Claudius to stop
this from happening in the future and
the entire episode is sort of a road
trip
Claude meets his brother at the location
of the festival and due to the events
last week he's pretty down on his luck
he's paranoid worried that someone is
stalking him and that something bad is
about to happen
Holly has either been watching these
videos or she's really smart and she's
deduced that Claude is going to be the
face that'll cuoco wears next in order
to stop it from framing another person
the group intend to follow Claude to
provide him with an alibi once the
creature does innovatively attack Holly
has worked out that the creature is at
its weakest whenever it's been exposed
and as it's already very vulnerable if
they expose it further then it could be
lights out for the monster ralph is
almost on board with the investigation
and the metaphor of the beetle from last
time has definitely come full circle
last week we saw one scrambling around
on its back and able to get up and thus
it was stuck in a position in which he
would die
there were several examples of this in
the entries such as Jack who did the
same thing but we cut from the beetle
almost immediately to Ralph lying in his
bed and he sat up showing that he wasn't
doomed however he still hums and Haws
and Jeanne tells him not to go on the
trip because she believes that if he
does it will stall the investigation
fair there al cuoco has managed to exist
for so long purely because of policemen
like Ralph who disregarded the
supernatural the greatest trick the
devil ever pulled was convincing the
world that he didn't exist and this is
exemplified here Ralph says that he will
be okay and no he doesn't out-and-out
say it it's clear that he's coming
around the beetle could have also been
applied to Al cuoco who he learned was
also in a very bad position before they
head out we see how Ian Ralph catch up
and the Fulmer says that glory is going
to be soon the department but that he'll
not be brought into it he's dodged a
bullet because glory thinks that Ralph
is the only person who can clear Terry's
name we cut to Jack who as an APB out on
him and
learn about his backstory we discovered
that he's an expert marksman however he
failed the psych evaluation at the Army
Jack's dream was to be a sniper but at
the last minute he was rejected and this
has haunted him his entire life we know
that al cuoco picks vulnerable people to
be its slaves and he was clearly chosen
because of this this was coupled with
the death of his mother and the fact
that his wife left him and yeah he was
just ripe for the picking the
conversation slowly turns to a cuoco and
ralph hypothetically says that he's been
sold on it and we learned that its
motives are merely to survive as Holly
says it's not a criminal it's not human
it's something else now the book by
Stephen King was supposed to take the
idea of the serial killer and turn it
into something supernatural we exist in
a world where people murder for
absolutely no reason beyond the fact
that they like to do it what King wanted
to put across with the work is what if
people like Jeffrey Dahmer you used to
kill and cannibalize what if he really
was a monster a creature from another
world a vampire that could take the face
of someone that seemed like a normal
person and wear it like a mask this
would allow them to blend in and hide
their deepened dog desires this metaphor
is laced throughout the season and
especially in this episode with masks
making a big appearance towards the end
with Claude speaking of Claude he ends
up staying at the family home with his
brother his brother is putting together
a jigsaw without knowing what the image
actually looks like and to me this
comments on Ralph's investigation the
spa Ralph has been trying to put the
pieces of the puzzle together without
accepting the bigger picture however he
will eventually get there through sheer
willpower Holley solves the jigsaw
without even looking at it and this
clearly shows that she's been brought
into the investigation to provide a
high-level view Holly also says that she
doesn't like elephants and this is
possibly because like her they never
forget we cut to Eunice and Andy in the
car and Eunice jokingly tells him that
Holly consents when people are going to
die to me this kind of shows our myth
and folklore can be developed and now we
know el Coco is real it also shows why
people have such a hard time believing
things when they can just be made up so
easily and gullible people can jump on
board even
if deep down they know it's not true
back in the other car Ralph tells Holly
that he was a respected policeman but
that he's now chasing the boogeyman
Holly appreciates him calling around
question her and he says that this is
challenging this is a callback to the
jigsaw puzzle which is too difficult but
worth doing for the mental strain er
will provide that will help us grow in
the long run the to confide in one
another on the ride and Ralph tells a
story about when his son was born in
which he heard the same song that he
tried to play his mother the day that
she died she mentioned it as she was
dying and Ralph ran down to get it and
then came up to find her dead he still
played it to her and said that he never
heard it again until the time that he
was talking to his mother in his head
about how he wished that she could see a
grandchild that song was Washington
Square which ergo listen to it tons of
comments on there about how the outsider
brought us there and yeah it's a nice
little song it had me crying a bit
especially after this story and it's
very emotional I think it was a joke but
there may have been some truth to it so
let me know your thoughts in the
conversation below and what it
represented for you Polly begins to
embrace the other side and visits the
church later in the episode we learn
that Claude's brother was taking
anger-management classes and I have a
theory that L cuoco may have wanted to
choose him as the next slave after Jack
had been rumbled
he's clearly caught up in narcotics
close to the victim like Tracy and his
cousin and he lives an isolated life
this won't happen but yeah that's just
kind of what I guessed Claude is stopped
by police and taken to jail and it
doesn't take too long before his brother
is in the cell with them after storing a
fight of the department elsewhere jack
is now hunting the most dangerous game
man
and he Snipes a fisherman we then hear
the son of a cuckoo feasting for the
first time jack has to ditch his car
because of the APB but there's no reason
I'll Kukoc on it either the animal
noises are mixed in with human breathing
and though we don't see anything it's
completely disgusting l cuoco and Jack
are making a road trip like the other
characters but this one doesn't look
like I'll be as fun al cuoco is taking
Claude's voice his tattoos and the
creature says that he needs to eat
because the fisherman was full of cancer
this explains why he chooses young
targets as children are far less likely
to have
cancer than adults he also feeds on the
grief of families so he takes a cube
from the front mirror that has pictures
of them on it we can actually see from
its hands that it isn't fully
transformed yet and we learned that the
reason it adopts a mask layer is to hide
the fact that its face is still a bit
mushed it still has cords DNA though so
that's enough to frame them but the
investigation has clearly made it up
route we then join a family making their
own road trip to cave stock and as
mentioned earlier this becomes out
cuccos new base elites there too and
seems displeased with the meals that
Jack has been bringing it it's revealed
that Ralph and Co are the ones that had
Claude arrested and it was for his own
safety they give him the full 1/1 and
Ralph is still struggling he's slowly
getting there
but it is a bit frustrating to see him
doing a Dana Scully
when Mulder has already shown her aliens
for like the 2000 time the outsider
becomes fixated on the child from the
family at the festival and he promises
to show the boy the caves his sister
also had some predators around her two
boys why I oughta
luckily the boys point out cuoco and his
sister screams and stops her brother
from being taken away a crowd gather and
the father manages to pull his mask off
later in the episode we see al Coco's
face and it confirms that it's not fully
transformed yet the church scene happens
and we cut to the police station namely
the investigation of the attempted
kidnapping
we then jump to the crew at Claude's
family home and Ralph is awoken by
Claude in the night going through the
paranoia that he talked about earlier
the next day how he and Alex arrived due
to the guilt of feeling like they'd
abandon Holly similar to everyone else
in the episode Alex had a sign that
something was going to happen on this
trip because of the taste of copper in
his mouth this used to happen before his
tours in Iraq and thus he knows it's a
very important mission police show up to
question Claude and they have cell phone
footage of the character attempting to
kidnap the boy Ralph can't deny Ikuko
exists and Holly says he is here the
song at the end is called una thigh by
al michaels affair if you want to know
because I absolutely loved it and we end
with al cuoco eating at the air and next
week it looks like everyone is finally
on the hunt for it al cuoco is hungrier
than ever before
and they know where it is in the cave
everyone arms up and goes in the hunt
but it looks like it won't be easy jack
similar to the book is set up in a
sniper's position and ready to shoot
anyone who comes into contact with it
it looks like there's also a cave
collapse and personally I think that
this is how the episode will end with us
potentially getting a cliffhanger just
before the finale either way it looks
great and the promo really got my blood
pumping for next week
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on episode 8 and what you've
thought of the season so far
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up if you missed any of our
episodes and they're gonna be linked at
the end every month on the 15th we give
away free blu-rays and all you have to
do to be in with a chance of winning the
Infinity Saga box set its label like and
subscribe with notifications on if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below you can
also come chat to us on our discord
server which is gonna be linked below or
at definition whitey those are the best
ways to keep up to date with the channel
so hopefully I see you over there very
soon this is a channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time
take care peace
you